We are here with George Oliphant,
from "George To The Rescue"
helping us with a special design Drew over on spackling.
And he's teaching us how to empower ourselves
and take business into our own hands.
Exactly.
Yes.
You can do it.
Everyone can do it.
This is not hard.
Okay, so before the break, we backed, we spackled,
we scraped, we let it dry, now what do we do?
Okay, so now what you're gonna do
is you would sand where your repair is.
Sand it all down.
This is gonna dry.
It sands off really nicely.
You get it nice and smooth.
And then after you sand it,
you are going to, you're gonna prime it.
(audience applauds)
Bravo. Bravo.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Like a pro.
Thank you.
Then you prime it.
Okay.
So it's already actually
I think these have already been primed,
this one has definitely been primed.
This one has not, but that's all right.
The importance to priming.
That is a very important step.
A lot of times people will skip the priming step.
Do not do that because if you ever notice
you're sitting in a room and you look at a wall
and even though it's all the same color,
you can see that there was once a patch there,
that's because somebody didn't prime it.
That's called flashing.
And so if you prime it,
that way the paint will all adhere equally
to your repair and to the wall.
I haven't been primed?
Well, it looks like there's a little primer on there.
There's some primer on there.
Primer. Primer.
You have prime.
Do you guys, anybody here ever paint without priming?
I'm so guilty of it.
'Cause I'm like, paint it white.
What? And then paint it?
It's double the work.
Well, there's a lot of options to that.
There's some compounds come with primer in it.
Some paints come with primer in it,
but it's always a good idea to prime it.
And then yes, you just roll it out.
Now, there's times where you can use a brush
and there's times where you wanna use a roller.
When you're on a wall, you wanna use a roller.
It's gonna give you a much more even finished product.
That way you don't get like brush marks or anything.
Brushes are great, obviously,
if you're working in corners
or if you're working on trim or bookshelves
or something like that.
But for this wall-
This is so satisfying.
Yeah, and then just roll it.
This is exactly what I look like too.
Ta-da! Look at that.
I would give it maybe one more coat.
Leave it to dry, and then get it with a second coat.
And I am so inspired.
Oh no, no, no.
My second coat's not going well.
That's all right, that's all right.
You're good. You're good.
Don't press too hard.
Let the tool do the work.
That's another problem.
Sometimes with people with rollers, they push real hard.
Let the roller just roll, and you'll be good to go.
That way you don't get roller marks,
you don't get brush marks.
What do you if you get paint on your blazer?
Oh no.
That's a whole different type of rescue.
Drew's so excited.
You can take this out.
Oh God, let me get it.
Let me at it.
Let me at it. Don't touch it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Well, gosh, George, everything I do is like way too much,
and I did press really hard
No, no, no.
on my roller.
You did great
You did fantastic.
All right, is it okay?
I will say we learned so much today.
I can't even see the repair.
You fixed it. It's gone.
You made a good repair.
You did a good job.
You guys are pros.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Help me out anytime.
George, can you please come back?
I would be honored to.
Thank you.
There's so much we have to learn from you.
There's a lot to fix in people's houses.
I'm happy to help anytime.
There's a lot to fix in life.
This is true.
Well, thank you, George Oliphant so much.
"George To The Rescue" is streaming on Peacock.
And a new season will premier on March 26 on NBC.
(upbeat bright music)